theatrical movie trailers bring out the
emotions in all of us let's watch
three I went online this morning and I
rented us beautiful house out by the
beach I figured if I made the
reservation and packed our bags it would
eliminate white
woman it's surprise can go on vacation
at any time oh this is nice expensive
house so
happy
pool the Wi-Fi is
uh-oh white people without internet God
she has Starbucks what could be at the
door the worst of I'm sorry to bother
this
is black
child black people have a house like
this we were driving back to the city
then something happened you want to stay
here but we're staying
here people black people can't share
[Music]
things they need to think everything's
going to be okay
everything is going to be okay isn't
it we are seeing on cyber attacks across
the country Donald Trump might shut off
the internet something is happening and
I don't trust them she does not
everything I know I have told you I
don't believe you I would do anything to
protect my family white guy with a gun
is your business
Tesla El musk b car right
now look at this Tesla's destroying the
world look the crazy
cars haven't you been picking up on
what's going on out
there whatever it is it's happening to
all of
us I just want the Mexican woman in the
car what is the
truth
[Music]
oh I have mentioned this movie a couple
times on the show in the last week
because I watched it purely for
sociological purposes like I normally I
like sci-fi stuff but I have no desire
to watch an Obama produce thing you need
if you have Netflix you need to watch
this movie because it's not only because
it's obvious predictive programming but
the racial tension they put in there for
no reason in a dystopian movie uh
there's some weird things about the show
Friends kids love friends and they try
to make friends seem crappy there's
there it's just watch it watch it just
to see what's going the the that Obama
wanted to put these ideas into young
people's heads I don't like him or his
husband all right what's
up whose land is this oh this one looks
good might try to watch this one this
week a flower Moon well our war hero has
arve you made a good choice calling back
here who says are the finest wealthiest
and most beautiful people on God's Earth
yeah out smart
everybody they have the say who gets the
oil son I got a question you like women
that's my
weakness Leo playing himself we mix
these families together and that estate
money flows the right direction it'll
come to
us that's how you are I don't know what
you said but it must have been Indian
for handsome devil
why did you come
here I work with my
uncle you scared of him oh he's a he's
the nicest man in the
world the old s their time is over we
got to take back control of our
home I was sent down from Washington DC
to see about these
murders we have so many deaths we've
lost count this just bad luck seems more
like an epidemic than bad luck to
me oh say just dying by the enemy do not
let them die
alone evil surrounds my
heart you going to pick a side
I don't even know if you loved me
anymore of course I love you and kill
these men who killed my
family did your wife say who she was
most afraid
[Applause]
of don't do something you're going to
regret for the rest of your
life oh that looks good I ain't got
nothing but
gra yeah that looks good that's it sort
of looks like a dark version of um not
Last of the Mohicans what was the Kevin
CER movie uh uh Kevin Cosner the Indian
movie oh my God come on oh Field of
Dreams no Field of
Dreams water world no come on Dances
with Wolves of course it looks like a
like
a
avatar yeah that looks good all right
I'm going to watch that this week I'll
get back for that one on the new year
we'll we'll report back on that one all
right I think we got one more for
you hey Kei you know I did my first
toast and butter cartoon in the bathroom
wall it's still there Dave Ruben story
someone you a and toast mouth oh I was
drunk okay I thought that was you I'm an
artist it's important to preserve little
mystery you're not mysterious Lenny
Kravitz he's mysterious Lenny kravit
Batman you on your way to the top
newspapers TV show movie deals so you're
ke KN I am it's funny I didn't think
you'd
be tall happens all the time I just love
your work and what you say with it why
is it that as people of color always
having to stand for something in our
work just a cartoonist because the
world's a racist place and that's why I
keep it light keep it light yeah keep it
light don't move the suspect question
you got the wrong
guy copy that this isn't the suspect I
can't believe they did us like that are
you
cool over here man miss policeman did a
numb on you didn't he now you can be his
it's just like having a super power if
crazy was a
superow by a true story the man talking
earlier I got my ass beat by the police
now I'm seeing they are Houston we have
a problem
first man you woke happy birthday let
pop bottles make cupcakes did you guys
lighten my photo I look like Sammy Sosa
uh am I too black for my own comic trust
me no one's going to ever accuse you of
being too black I'm sorry
what down here my brother that's right
I'm a talking trash can this is all
wrong I tell you what's wrong those man
bun co-opting Ginger fine Devils so you
have about 30 minutes till they trap you
in the S place it feels like I'm already
there if you were me what would you do
you let this out so you have to deal
with it The Good the Bad and the Ugly
you know what to
do boy I ain't
got this is that moment in The Matrix do
I take the red pill or the blue pill
I've got both in my room if you want to
experiment Merry
Christmas